thank you very much um first of all i
would like to thank uh the organizers
for allow allowing me
to
to give a talk at this exciting workshop
and i would like to also thank all of
them for coming to this talk so today i
would like to talk about uh
roughly speaking eigenvectors of tensors
so
the purpose is twofold the first one is
to talk about eigenvectors of matrices
but
from coming from a commutative algebra
point of view
and then
the second part is going to be
my my purpose of the second part is to
introduce the concept of eigenvectors
to tensors
so my plan is to end this talk with a
theorem
really related to
eigen
vectors of tensors
proved by using algebraic geometry by
some of the people in this audience
okay
so i uh here's the notation i'm going to
use through this talk
so let me start with the definition of
eigenvector so it sounds
insulting to you but um
anyway
so let's suppose you have an n by n
matrix so let's say
a
and the nonzero vector v
is called
eigenvector
of this matrix a
if it's a constant lambda
such that
av
is equal to
the multiplication of this vector by
lambda
right
so that means
a times b and b
are parallel
so therefore we can
interpret this definition in the
following way so namely
if you take the wedge product of these
two vectors this is going to give zero
and
the second extra extra
so let me give
to remarks
so the first three mark is kind of
obvious so
a b wedge b
is equal to the zero vector for
every vector sitting inside b if and
only if
a is a scalar multiplication nonzero
scalar multiplication of the identity
matrix
the first remark
and the second remark is so let's
write i sub a
for the ideal
generated by
the entries
of
a x
wedge x so
so this i sub a sits inside the
polynomial ring c i joined x 0 up to x n
minus 1 and x
arrow denotes the
vector of variables from x 0 to x n
minus 1.
so an i sub a is generated by entries of
this guy so this guy
so if you use the macaulay 2 you can
compute
this ideal by typing
miners
so this indicates you have to take all
the two by two minus of the following
matrix namely
ax so this is a
n by one vector
and a content you concatenate
uh
this these two vectors side by side and
take that all the 2 by 2 miners
and those 2 by 2 miners generate this
idea
so and
by definition
is an eigenvector
of the matrix a
if on the only if
the equivalence class of this
nonzerector piece
sits inside
the projective
i mean algebraic set defined by this i
sub a
so that means this v of i sub a can be
viewed as the union of all possible
eigen spaces of the
the matrix
if a is
diagonalizable then
this ideal a
equals
the radical of
this ideal
so if you use mccoy 2.
a radical
and after that
right isabey as an input
these two conditions are actually equal
equivalent
so
here's my question the question i'm
interested in
so what
can
commutative algebra or algebraic
geometry
tell us about
the matrix
is not diagonalizable
so the goal of the first part of this
talk is to answer
this question
so let me clarify
what means what i mean by that
so um
so i classified a three by three three
by three matrices in terms of the number
of distinct eigenvectors
and the number of jordan blocks and i
think if i did it correctly you have one
two three four five
six uh so these six cases
okay
so this table captures uh all the
possible configurations of eigenvectors
for example if
a three by three matrix is
diagonalizable i mean i mean the three
distinct eigen
vector values or problems three
eigenvalues
it is diagonalizable
and you have three distinct points and
these three points are not collinear
and if a three by three matrix has only
two eigen distinct eigenvalues and you
have two cases one had one has three
jordan blocks and the other one had two
jordan blocks okay so if it has three
jordan blocks that means a is
diagonalizable in this case you get a
point which corresponds to as
an eigenvector of one of the eigenvalues
and you have a line which corresponds to
the eigenspace of another eigenvalue
okay but if
it has two only two jordan blocks you
have a point
and you have some skinny stuff here
this scheme stuff here actually
remembers this comes from a line so if
you only consider the algebraic set
corresponding to i sub a you don't get
that information
okay so the question is how can i get
this skinny stuff
by using community algebra so one way to
do it is
to compute the priority decomposition
so i'm not going to talk about the
remaining cases but hopefully you
understand what i'm going to do
so do you have questions so far
okay so
how can i attack such a such a problem
so i sub a is generated by quadratic
polynomials
but if a is generic
and these two quadratic polynomials are
not really friendly okay
so
idea is to reduce this problem to the
case where a is a jordan matrix so the
question is why can we do this
excuse me
here is one paw patrol
let's suppose you have two matrices of
the same size
okay
let's assume they are similar
this means that it's
an invertible matrix c
such that b can be written as c inverter
c inverse times a times c
so then you can consider two ideals
associated with a and b
but they only differ
by
the linear
change of
coordinates
given by sending
x
to
c times x
so that means if you have a matrix a so
a linear algebra one of the linear
algebra
theorems tells us you can always reduce
a matrix to a jordan canonical form okay
so this orbital tells us
so we may assume
hey
now let's assume uh let's write
json lavda
for
a jordan matrix
with a single eigenvalue
data
okay
then the next proportion tells us all we
have to do is basically
to consider
uh
the ideal associated way associated with
a jordan matrix with a single variable a
single eigenvalue
so what do i mean by this so let me
write the next proposition
so let's pick two distinct
complex numbers
let's consider
the corresponding
matrices
it might be of different sizes
and i'd like to consider
the point in a
polynomial ring
now
this hat this ring has two sets of
different variables
x and y's
i'm interested in the ideal coming from
the direct sum of
these two matrices
sorry c cm by cm
thank you cm cross cm thank you
so this idea can be written as
the intersection of the
following two ideals
it's generated by
this guy
plus wise
the other guy
the other ideal
is numeric by generated by this these
quadratic polynomials plus
x
variable x i's
okay
let me
just discuss
one example
okay um
so
i would like to consider a graph called
a
complete bipartite graph
so it consists of two sets of vertices b
and w and the edge set
so b has
and it's
vertices and w hats
and
two
vertices are adjacent if and only if
so one of them is
v the other one should be
in
so the easiest
one one simple example is k23 so you
have
two sets of
two vertices vertex sets
and one has two elements and the other
one has three elements
so this is
the
complete
pipe bipartite graph k23
so now what i'd like to consider is
so-called
monomial edge ideal
meaning if v i w j
is an edge
then we consider x i yj as a generator
so you have
for example in this case you have six
such monomials and those monomials
generate the ideal
so the question is
what does it have
or what is the relationship between this
monomial ideal and the ideal i'm talking
about what associated with a matrix
so let's
consider two
distinct complex numbers alpha and beta
and
it denotes the scalar multiplication of
the identity matrix by alpha
and b is the scalar multiplication of
the identity
matrix by beta
okay and the claim is uh
so
you have this block diagonal matrix a
plus
a plus b
so this guy is equal to
it's ideal of the complete by heart
height graph
so
this is
it's very simple so
if you consider
zero
so that means uh
non-zero
entries
of
these are
alpha x i times y j minus
theta x
i times y j
which turns out to be alpha minus beta
x
okay
so our assumption was alpha and beta are
distinct either
complex numbers
so
the generators of this guy and the
generators of this guy are only
different by constants
so that's why these two ideas are the
same so now i would like to use this
proportion to
to compute a primary conversion
by using this proportion too it can be
written as
the intersection of this idea
but we know
this is equal to zero
primary decomposition actually prime the
composition in this case
is the intersection of these two
so i i think this is a very simple
example but the point is
um
since you have this proposition you can
decompose the ideal associated with a
matrix by induction
okay
so
that means this proportion allows us to
reduce
what just uh
we can restrict our attention
two
eight children
matrix with a single
eigenvalue
so
okay
so now i need some
location let's fix a
a
positive integer l and for each i
between one and l
i consider performing two sets of uh
non-negative integers of positive
integers
a i and rri
but with
this order okay
and
j sub lambda comma ri
is
a jordan block of size ri
that means
this denotes this matrix
k i times
j
lambda comma r i
is just the direct
sum
of
k ki copies of
the jordan blocks of the same size
then
draw the matrix with a single eigenvalue
can be written as
volts
so every journal matrix with a single
eigenvalue can be written as
as this
after
a permutation of job blocks
so the question is what can we say
about
this
dota matrix
using a clean article
okay so now for hj
between one l
that is ideal
i sub j
some viables
such that
this is the idea we are interested in
can be written as the intersection of
these ideals
and
the hubert polynomial
of this quotient ring
is
ri
times
t plus
k
1 plus all the way up to k
j minus 1 choose
okay so you can use my color too
notation
so this means the hibernate polynomial
of
the project space of the sides times rj
okay
so
i i think i
told two lights in the abstract i said
so i'm going to talk about the primary
decomposition and i was
not able to prove this is a primary
conclusion but this is kind of
appropriate
so since i don't know i didn't tell you
how to pick variables i'm going to tell
you how to do it in the following
example
so more precisely uh each ideal is so
called a cell the cellular uh ideal so
this is a cellular decomposition
and thomas kell and thomas cowell and i
are trying to prove each ideal is a
primary guide here
work on progress
but uh i think the point is if you're
able to find this decomposition you can
recover uh the information about your
mechanical forms meaning
for example you can find if you compute
the decomposition the number of the
composition tells you the number of
different
sizes of jordan blocks
okay
and each size can be
obtained as the degree
okay
and the each hubert polynomial contains
linear equations of k 1 up to k l
so you have n linear equations in n
variables and all you have to do is to
solve this system and this system to get
k 1 through k l i k
l
so you can recover all the information
about jordan's structure
by computing
all right did you say what l is
l is um
that number of
different sizes of jordan blocks
so let me qualify so
in order to state
this decomposition i have to prepare
more notations that complicates the talk
so i'm going to just give you
a an example and tell you how you can
pick variables to find
these distinct couples
so did i understand right that the
missing part is sort of to prove that if
you just have one block and its primary
no
no each each ideal appearing is the
composition is a primary idea
that's my my that's what
i hope and macaulay 2 actually tells us
this is probably the case
and i i was kind of amazed that if you
run this
uh if you compute the uh the primary
ideal by using macaulay 2 you get the
same decomposition
so there must be some good reason why
because typically primary decomposition
algorithm doesn't necessarily become
possibly ideal by
binomial ideals
now if you start with just a single
block yeah not not multiple as you have
there
like this yeah yeah
then
the uh then you'll put
one
in your intersection right yeah and you
would like to claim that that's
private
so
you know it's a free resolution
i don't know it's something i haven't
done yet
i don't know
it's good to know whether or not the
free resolution also encodes the same
kind of information and i think i i
believe i
i guess it does
yeah i also computed on the radical of
each
idea appearing in this decomposition
it's just a linear linear subspace
so you will see in the following example
right now by that
so let's consider
uh the this case so it has three jordan
blocks oh i'm sorry
so the first one has size four sides the
second one has size three
and our wing is c a joint x zero
after x eight
so
what i'd like to do in this example is
how you can define this i j okay in this
case you have
three
as i1 through i3
so who i i won all you have to do is
take
these variables and the second one you
can pick this
and these two and the third one
you have to pick x2 and x3
and x6
okay so
what i meant is
i1 consists of
x4
through x8
and i2
consists of
x3
and x7 and x8
and x3
x2 and x3
and
x6
so i think you can see the pattern how
to pick the variables
ah
so uh so
yeah so the bottom line was
communicative algebra tells us something
about the jordan structure of the matrix
i'm sorry i'm not sure if i see the
password
yeah i'm sorry i agree oh i'm sorry um
so for the first one
so the first uh variables correspond to
the first
jordan block and this block responds
with this guy and this block responds to
this guy the first one
you only consider uh you get rid of the
the variables corresponding to this guy
okay and the throw in all the remaining
variables
in i1 so that's that's probably easy
all right so
uh
next one
so next one is
so um
you only consider the variables
correspond to the third one so that
means these two plus the last
variable
of the first group why only the last one
what if i want the last one
it just isn't this
and the last one
yeah why do you not also throw in x0 x1
x2 into group two
what's the question
um
uh the the um the short answer is it
doesn't give me the idea i want
how did you know
that x3 would give you the idea you want
but not the other one
um
i asked mccoy too
so that means i computed a bunch of
examples and i realized that's a pattern
there's no
good reason i don't miss that i don't
know how i can explain why this is the
pattern i have to use
this is the this is based on the
macaulay 2-based analysis
and
yeah
so each time you increase the number of
variables
here the next time for example you have
so
so hopefully um anyway so i'm gonna if
you're interested in i'm going to talk
about this in after the talk i'm sorry i
thought this might be
this might kill you
third chance that
a different pattern would give you the
same minimal primes but different
primary ideals associated
mdd
i think so but all the primes me
yes uh no no what do you mean by that
is or not
for each ideal uh
so
so i mean
these are embedded primes the first one
the second one
so this is the largest one so if you
compute
the prime the composition only up here
is the radical of the last one
so the first two are embedded primes
responding to the convective products
okay i'm sure you have some questions i
understand you have some questions but i
would like to clarify those questions
after the talk and
may i move to the second part
so
so i talked about uh eigenvectors of
matrices and the purpose of the second
part is to show you how you can extend
the concept of eigenvector of a matrix
to an eigenvector of s
so
the definition looks a little scary but
i'm gonna talk about a few examples
hopefully that clarifies
the definition
so let's consider
an element of
the tensor product of d
the copies of the
nodes
v o times
for each eye
i not
you can define
an element of b all times sd minus one b
star
so sd minus one b star is v star is the
dual of b so this is just d minus first
symmetric power of b star so this can
also
be viewed as
the set of linear transformation
from this d minus 1 b
so i'm going to define this element as
follows
is either component of this guy
is equal to
a point polynomial
so if d is equal to two it's just a
linear trans ah linear form
okay
that corresponds ax
this is kind of uh generalization of ax
here is the definition of a pencil
either vector
so this definition is due to
leg handling
so a non-zero vector b
in in the vector space b is called
an eigenvector
of t
if
the equivalence class containing this b
sits inside
and then alter except
so
the notation might be might look a
little scary so let's
let's discuss
one example
to gain more understanding of the
definition
okay in this example
v denotes
c2
another
point
uh 2 by 2 by 2
tensor okay so the first term is e zero
o times e zero four times e zero
plus square root of negative one times e
zero o times d zero o times e one
plus e one o times e 1 4 times e 0
minus 1
times e 1
4 times
so now i what i do is to find an item
back to eigenvectors of this pencil
okay
so to do so i'd like to rewrite this
expression the following way so
this can be written as e zero four times
e zero o times e zero plus square root
of negative one
times d zero times d one
plus
e one four times
four 4 times e 0
plus derivative of negative 1 times mu 1
over x
so what this division tells us is
the first component
corresponds to this guy and all you have
to do is replace x dxi
with items of e i by x i okay so that
means
t x 2
is equal to
x del squared which corresponds to e 0
times e 0
plus
square root of negative 1 times
x 0
negative square root of 1 times e0 or
times e1
so likewise the second component is
going to be x0 x1
plus square root of negative 1
that's x y squared
so i think uh this example is related to
the first exercise problem of the
following set so
if you have some questions please do not
paste it and just ask do you understand
what we are doing
okay
so now
the next
thing i would like to do is to find out
what the eigenvectors are so all we have
to do is the same as
the matrix case that means
take the wedge product of this vector
and the vector of variables
but
so you can basically make a two by two
uh two by two matrix and compute the
determinant
but uh this can be written as
x zero plus square root of negative one
x 1 times x 0 and x 1.
so if you take the weight product of
this guy
and the vector of variables what do what
do you get
so which means
every nonzero vector
so
maybe it would be better for this
definition to call this like a one
eigenvector
because depending on where you're doing
the contracting
so you're contracting in in slots two up
to d right in the first thing this one
then the the other panel
yeah
okay yeah so you're contracting in slots
two up to d
and then wedging would to get a vector
in the first slot
but if you if you contract in some other
set since you're not dealing with
symmetric you could end up with
different set of eigenvalues
so i i certainly understand what you're
saying
okay
okay
so
now
so we are identifying b and its draw by
using uh the
standard basis and its dual basis
okay so that means
using that
identification
you can also define
an eigenvector of a homogeneous
polynomial
uh
namely
v
i
it's said to be
i get
of
f
if then only if
this vector sits inside
the
zero set of the point set of polynomials
so this nabla f it's just a
gradient i have committed so let me give
at least one example
i would have to consider uh itenary form
so f of x
is equal to
let's say
xs cubed
plus x1 cubed and i would actually
compute the eigenvectors of this form
so in order to do so the first step is
to compute the gradient
of this polynomial in this case
the first component is going to be 3 x 0
squared and the second component is
3x1 squared and the last one is zero
okay
the next step is to take
the which
product of
this vector and the vector variables
okay so that means you have a three by
two matrix and you have to consider all
possible two by two minus in this case
you have three such two by two minus and
each minus gives you a cubic
okay so the first one is
this
binomial
the second one and the third one are
just monomials
okay so now i would like to find out uh
the ideal associated with
this cubic form
and so compute a two by two minus and
then ask macquarie to compute the
primary decomposition then you will get
x zero squared x y squared
the last one is x2 minus x1 max 2.0
so this is the primary decomposition
so this gives you the following
configuration
um
so you have
three four points
but this point
has
so that means if you compute the prime
decomposition you get four points but if
you compute a primary decomposition you
get three distinct points but they are
called linear
plus one distinguished point which which
can be viewed as a support of the scheme
of length four
so let me give one more example
the first one
now let's consider
x 0
q plus x 1 cubed plus x 2
cubed and the gradient of this
polynomial
is
three x two squared and three x one
squared
and three x two squared
let's compute the ideal associated with
this tensor i'm sorry a cubic form
now i'm not going to write down the
primary decomposition but i'm going to
write down the correspond pounding
configuration of eigenvectors which kind
of beautiful
so you have all together seven points
and the seven points
uh form the configuration
and so
um
this type of of symmetric tensor is
called orthogonally decomposable
symmetric tensor
and
so elena
studied
are all possible fortunately the
comfortable cases and she found out all
the possible configurations of python
vectors of such such such a test
so let me ask one question
one question
and i'd like to state one theorem and
i'd like to finish the talk
so the question is what is the number
of vectors
of a tensor provided that a tensor has
finitely many many eigenvectors okay
so for example we consider two cases one
was this one the other one was uh
x zero squared plus x plus answer x one
x zero cubed plus x one cubed
and
count it with multiplicity
so both are of cubic forms and accounted
multiplicity counted about with
multiplicities both gets both have both
have seven eigenvectors okay so
so numbers of eigenvectors are are
invariant
on the
degree of a polynomial for example so
is that a restriction or question
so that's an assertion or a question
this one no no the
very
diagonal
this is the theorem i'm going to tell
you
so this theorem is due to dusting
cut right
but also
due to
blue
so if the tensor t
has
eigenvectors
then
the number of eigenvectors
both are counted with multiplicity
so here i'm assuming that d in sphere
3
is
d minus 1
to the n power minus 1 divided by
d minus 2
okay especially if
e is equal to 3
it is going to be d squared minus b plus
1 so if b is equal i'm sorry n is equal
to 2
n is equal to 2 it's going to be d
squared minus d plus 1 so if d is equal
to 3 so 9 minus
3 plus 1 which is seven so that
is exactly what
examples suggest
so um
so the theme was proven
by
uh these these people and that they use
different
tools from algebraic geometry and my my
point is algebraic geometry or committed
algebra can solve some of the problems
in multi
linear algebra
related to
so either vectors
so thank you
questions for you
know
structure of the scheme corresponding to
matrix so
my
hope is
we can do the same thing but uh on the
other hand there are different kinds of
concepts of eigen tensors and i don't
know which concepts we can use to say
something like this
so yeah
so um when you look at the primary
decomposition of all these hypersurfaces
do you see a pattern in the primary
decomposition of y of f
so
in the second example i'm guessing that
you know what the primary decomposition
of i of f is
right
did you compute the primary
decomposition yeah yeah for those
examples yeah and so if i look at all
the vermont hyper surfaces right if i
look at now x naught to the fourth plus
x one to the fourth plus x two to the
fourth
the decomposition of iff have a similar
pattern yeah that's what elin
especially if
the polynomial can be written as
so-called
ultimately decomposable symmetric cancer
then the primary decomposition is no
but the other cases
you can say something about the primary
decomposition if the rank of the
polynomial is very small like one or two
but uh
yeah
it's a wide open question but one and
two is completely characterized yeah
it's very yeah so for example two you
always get this this kind of coffee
relationship
no more questions thank you